européen la parole est à monsieur pierre
lequiller monsieur le premier ministre
au lendemain du référendum sur le bric
site françois hollande annoncé pour la
énième fois que la france serait à
l'initiative pour que l'europe se
concentre sur l'essentiel et en
particulier l'harmonisation fiscale et
le renforcement de la zone euro et de sa
gouvernance
aujourd'hui toujours rien la vérité
c'est que françois hollande parle
bavarde beaucoup même ces temps ci mais
ne s'occupe pas des véritables enjeux
la vérité c'est que l' influence de la
france n'aurait on écoute laquelle a
fortement reculé depuis quatre ans la
tâche est immense certes mais est
urgente
face aux nombreuses crises que traverse
l'europe quand avec l'allemagne d'autres
et vous la zone euro d'une gouvernance
économique avec harmonisation fiscale
d'une politique industrielle et d'une
politique énergie commune
kan devant la crise migratoire vous
engagerez vous vers une modification en
profondeur du système de schengen
aujourd'hui effondré en le dotant comme
nous le proposons d'une direction
politique en harmonisant au préalable et
politique d'asile et en renforçant
considérablement frontex pour protéger
efficacement les frontières extérieures
de l'europe
quand serez-vous enfin clair sur le fait
que la turquie n'a pas vocation à entrer
dans l'union européenne la france a
depuis la création de l'europe toujours
contribué à faire avancer le grand
projet européen depuis 2012 françois
hollande n'offrent aucune vision poil et
dans les faits c'est vers l'allemagne
que le regard de nos partenaires sont
tournés le bric site est un séisme
devrait plus appelé au sursaut quand le
président de la république
mettra-t-il sur la table du conseil
européen des propositions concrètes pour
répondre aux nombreuses
crise que traverse l'europe si monsieur
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
pardon monsieur le président monsieur le
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président vous qui y est c'est les
sujets que vous connaissez via tinqueux
vous traiter régulièrement mais j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de vous répondre
parce que vous connaissez bien ses
sujets parce que vous êtes un européen
convaincu
je suis toujours étonné non pas du tout
mais et de la caricature de votre
question concernant l'engagement et la
politique du président la république ou
du gouvernement sur les questions
européennes
oui l'europe sans peut très vite se
mettre d'accord sur le constat est à la
croisée des chemins et les menaces et
même de délitement de disparition aux
yeux l'histoire le break si la menace
terroriste la crise des réfugiés
les tensions au sein même de l'union
européenne entre les anciens pays de
l'est
les anciens pays de l'ouest entre le
nord et le sud
nous le savons que ces crises exister il
faut en appeler en effet à un sursaut
mais pas à travers la cas la caricature
parce qu'enfin savez moi je peux
répondre de manière extrêmement précise
la zone euro qui étaient en très grande
tension en 2012 et je n'accuse pas le
président la république précédents d'en
porter la responsabilité a été
aujourd'hui stabilisé si la grèce est
resté dans la zone euro c'est grâce à
l'initiative du présent la république
françois hollande alors même que vous le
savez des voix s'élevaient en allemagne
pour faire en sorte que la grèce sorte
de la zone euro
si notre politique alors certains
voudraient que ça aille beaucoup plus
vite
mais si l'autre politique notre vision
sur la nécessité d'avoir davantage
d'investissements d'avenir
aujourd'hui avec le plan ukr d'avoir une
autre gouvernance en effet de l'euro à
notre rôle et notre politique de la
banque centrale européenne je l'avais
dit à cette tribune
au moment du discours de politique
générale si cette vision ces politiques
qui sont d'ailleurs plutôt françaises
quelles que soient les majorités sont
aujourd'hui au coeur des débats si
certaines d'entre elles elles sont mises
en oeuvre c'est parce que la voix de la
france compte si nous aurons l'occasion
de l'évoquer pour la crise ukrainienne
qui menace l'est de nos frontières les
frontières est de l'union européenne
si aujourd'hui malgré toutes les
difficultés il y à des solutions qui
sont recherchés c'est parce qu'il ya une
initiative commune de du président de la
république et la chancelière merkel qui
se retrouvent d'ailleurs ce soir avec
les présidents russe et ukrainien à
berlin sur la question des réfugiés
qu'on ne règle pas comme ça par une
caricature ou pas une seule question
parce que nous savons que c'est
particulièrement difficile mais ce sont
les positions de la france
défendu par bernard cazeneuve sur le pnr
ou sur les gardes-frontières qui
aujourd'hui sont mises en oeuvre est-ce
que c'est suffisant non il faut
évidemment aller plus loin et passe
crois que l'europe c'est une question de
frontières il faut ces protections aux
frontières communes de l'europe
vous parlez de la turquie oui moi je
crois qu'il faut des clarifications sur
la turquie
enfin ne soyez pas caricatural c'est
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
que son chapitre sur la turquie ont été
ouverts et je voudrais rappeler que les
positions parfois ambigu vis-à-vis de la
turquie ne date pas d'hier est en tout
cas le président jacques chirac mais un
carnet je crois avec un certain talent
donc sur tous ces risques majeurs qui
existe sur tous ces risques majeurs
il faut que nous avancions jean yves le
drian aura l'occasion dé revenir en face
il ya les initiatives difficile je
reconnais en matière de défense c'est
parce que précisément et l'allemagne et
la france sous l'impulsion du ministre
de la défense avance sur ces questions
là donc nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir oui faut un débat sérieux précis
parce que l'europe est en danger
oui beaucoup va passer par le couple
franco allemand
mais je pense que il faut sortir des
caricatures et je suis convaincu que sur
ces questions
les uns les autres et oublions les
primaires et les débats primaire quand
il s'agit de la politique nous pourrions
avancer intelligemment ensemble
merci monsieur le premier